behind their lawyer they filed in
together the family of Rashard Brooks
widow children cousins this was a moment
of raw grief up-close very public and
intended that way a moment for one
family to show what was taken from them
I can never get my husband back I can
never get my best friend I can never
tell my daughter oh he's coming to take
you skating or swimming lessons so it's
gonna be a long time before I heal it's
gonna be a long time before this family
here it was a family with a message if
you could just keep it as a peaceful
protest that would that would be
wonderful and a family with a demand the
trust that we have with the police force
is broken and the only way to heal some
of these wounds is through a conviction
and a drastic change with the police
department for 30 minutes on Friday
night two police officers questioned mr.
Brooks he'd fallen asleep in his car at
a local drive-through how many he
complied willingly throughout the
process he failed the test when they
tried to handcuff him he resisted
this reaction was natural his lawyer
says given what happened to a handcuffed
George Floyd three weeks ago he took one
of the officers taser stun guns he fired
it at them but was running away when he
was shot twice in the back
we got apologize do it for not telling
him that we loved him that much I'm
really not sure what else America needs
to see want to rerun a George Floyd
family I'm probably gonna be back here
in a few loves what another case
mark stone Sky News in Atlanta